la vérité est elle toujours bonne à dire
vous avez vos petites pancartes autour
de la table pourront jean michel vous
êtes partisan de la transparence du coup
oui je dis oui parce que je trouve que
la vérité finit toujours par éclater
donc mentir on finit toujours par se
faire choper moi par exemple à titre
personnel j'aurais adoré mentir mais je
ne sais pas mentir si elle quand je
mangeais les narines qui se dilate jauge
qui s'est toujours fait gauler donc j'ai
pris le parti assez rapidement de dire
la vérité voilà et puis je n'ai je
demande la même chose à mes proches mon
excellent me tromper assez souvent mais
je vous le disais je m'en fous un
bâtiment où tu me le dis parce que je
refuse de participer à ce dîner mais
voilà musulmans et seulement tu peux me
tromper si tu veux mais gilles moi parce
que le pire pour moi c'est de me dire
que tout le monde le sait sauf moi voilà
d'être jamais jamais c'est pas vraiment
le débat mais c'est quand même envie de
servir qu'il faut dire la vérité je
préfère la biographie ou est-ce que vous
restiez avec une femme qui vous tromper
tout le temps mais parce que tu vois on
dit la vérité
fidéle et des nouveaux fidèles et
exemplaire mais je n'ai pas exigé
vérité n'est pas forcément bonne a dit
est-ce que je peux relever un tout petit
peu le débat bien sûr merci à manacor
j'ai bien aimé c'est quoi aller j'aime
bien ce team bagman agathe c'est moi qui
prends allez je prends alors je suis
complètement d'accord avec vous à d'être
moi je ne peux je pense que jean michel
maire est un immense menteur oui sur ces
centaines voire sur son millier de
conquêtes je suis sûr qu'il a menti sur
au moins la moitié
donc aujourd'hui c'est le repas sera non
sur la vérité et sondage officiel bizot
trouver sur sur la vérité moi je pense
que la vérité est toujours bonne à dire
d'ailleurs on a parlé de mazarine
pingeot de la fille cachée de de
françois mitterrand d'état pendant mon
sens direction nouvelle très longtemps
mais je pense qu'il ya un avant/après
même dans le traitement médiatique
je pense que maintenant tout le monde
est bel est bien conscient que les
français préfèrent la transparence dans
la vie mais aussi dans la vie publique
de nos politiques etc il ya un an quand
vous étiez que chroniqueuse agathe on
avait reçu à gabriel attaque porte
parole du gouvernement et on avait eu un
débat sur les masques et moi je vous
l'avais dit que les français préféré que
des politiques disent je ne sais pas ce
que disent juste la vérité on attend
juste la vérité et on entre et on serait
on serait même amène à mieux de
comprendre sur la crise du coc vite ça a
été beaucoup reproché au gouvernement
son manque de transparence et que tous
les français tout le monde aurait
préféré des représentants politiques
qu'ils fassent preuve d'humilité en
disant bon bah là effectivement on a
déconné plutôt que dès aujourd'hui les
masques il n'y a pas besoin d'émettre
des masques fois que j'avais très bien à
la fin il y avait une tonne
d'informations extrêmement anxiogènes
moi je suis d'accord pour dire la vérité
effectivement quand elle sert quelque
chose quand il sert le débat et quand
elle fait avancer les lignes par exemple
lorsqu'on a montré les photos enfin la
vidéo d'ailleurs jack floyd
l'arrestation enfin l'assassinât
d'ailleurs de georgetown évidemment ça a
fait bouger les choses ça a donné
naissance au mouvement black la fma
d'heure et c'est donc ça c'était
intéressant après quand on montre le
petit le petit comment il s'appelait
elhanan il dit voilà le petit syrien de
trois ans mort voilà sur une plage
tuerait s'éteignent et terry devenu
horrible évidemment mais choc et
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas montré cette
image si elle fait bouger les choses
c'est ce qu'elle a fait bouger les
choses non pas du tout c'est censé être
le symbole de la crise migratoire
aujourd'hui oui c'est violent oui ça a
choqué est ce que ça a fait bouger des
lignes par rapport aux migrants 0 donc
il ya deux semaines sur ce traitement de
l'information justement de la vérité
utile ou pas rappelez-vous sur bfm le
journaliste dominique rizet avait
déclaré que deux personnes étaient en
train de se cacher dans l'hyper cacher
la prise d'otage était en cours donc
c'est là les limites aussi de cette
vérité de cette transparence à toute
épreuve les âmes vous vous êtes pour moi
j'ai été constante moi je suis
totalement pour parce que je pense que
voilà la vérité il faut qu'elles soient
dites et le fait que voilà les
journalistes des fois ils disent 'voilà
ok on veut pas dire la vérité parce
qu'on veut pas affoler le peuple etc moi
j'ai un peu l'impression que c'est comme
quand on excite dit non mais c'est fini
mais le problème c'est pas toi c moi ça
marche pas on s'excuse s'excuse fausse
excuse totalement en fait voilà moi je
suis une personne assez méchante de base
etc donc si en plus de ça maintenant que
je me méfie des médias s'ils ne disent
pas la vérité je préfère qu une totale
transparence et que et que nous dit à
chaque fois ce qu'il faut ce qu'il faut
entendre donc 900 exemple dans le
contexte actuel paul avec 7,7 ce
martèlement des informations sur les
conflits en cours et sert à ça peut pas
participer à une panique à une anxiété
néfastes dans la population au contraire
assez ça c'est justement c'est des fois
dire la vérité ça participe justement
une anxiété on a peur on ya des infos
que qui changent notre humeur qui nous
et qui nous font peur il nous faut agir
du coup de certaine manière ça chante ça
change nos vies aussi pour procéder pour
certaines fois mais c'est impossible de
dire toujours la vérité des dadas point
de vue immédiat alors on en parle on ne
sait pas quel type de personne n'est
derrière l'écran ça peut être un voleur
un dealer un tueur et pourtant combien
de fois dans des reportages ou autre on
nous a appris comment voler ou acheter
de la drogue et des armes voilà est donc
bon nous en tant que téléspectateur on
est client de ce genre de témoignage
mais à des personnes qui vont se nourrir
de ces infos là pour pouvoir passer à
l'action au mieux passer la santé des
personnes qui sont même pas au courant
de ces infos là et qu'ils vont avoir des
idées mal placées par la suite par
exemple le reportage sur
l'arnacoeur de tender quand tu vois que
le gars il a pris des millions il a
brisé des vies et koffi l'aller prend
cinq mois de prison tu as des gens qui
signe tout de suite pour cent
d'accord non je suis pas d'accord parce
que moi j'ai été du lait a éduqué avec
valeur et franchise et pour moi mentir
ça m'est totalement impossible et ça se
voit de suite sur mon visage je pense
que c'est de la main hier de faire des
médias qu'il faut que ça change
comment on nous dit les choses ne pas
nous affoler ou quoi enfin c'est
important c'est la façon comme exacts
l'agression physique adaptée hyper
importante en fait le problème de la
vérité c'est que chacun la sienne aussi
donc il ya une subjectivité c'est à dire
qu'il ya une question de point de vue
même chez un journaliste un journaliste
c'est d'abord un homme donc voilà c'est
le point de vue du journaliste
journaliste et simplement cette mission
d'objectivité parfaite personne ne
détient la vérité finalement là quand tu
relate des fétus relate des faits ont
lâché des faits pour paf les la
population sur sa comme le mensonge
sacré juste une chose le manque de
confiance on a par exemple la série n 26
ghana sur netflix on voit qu'un accès la
plus grande armée coeur de new york pour
ceux qui connaissent pas entre
guillemets aujourd'hui autour de la
table qui seraient prêts à les faire
confiance à une personne comme sa
personne parce qu'elle a menti à l'atria
et c'est moi quelqu'un qui me ment ou
qui cachent la vérité pour moi c'est
pareil et ça participe effectivement
elle a
découvert les médias est à mon sens j'ai
mon songe moi je dirais une anecdote
dans dire dans la vie personnelle aussi
tu es obligé de mentir ça soit le tas
monteur toi
[Rires]
la décharge de potes les menteurs se
reconnaissent entre eux
mais des fois t'es obligé je dirais les
anecdotes et franchement cela qui aurait
pas fait comme moi je pense que c'est
fort ce qu'il faut qu
on en sait un travail mon patron donc sa
femme accouche et donc je pouvais il
vient et il me dit voilà j'ai un fils
une explicitation et là il sort son
téléphone il montre une photo de son
fils et son fils il est moche
moche de ouf mais il n'a pas de
problèmes de sortie côte mais il est
moche ça arrive et moi je regarde la
photo je lui dit quoi et vous dites il
est magnifique je lui dis quoi je parle
des frérots ton fils y ressemble à ma
fesse gauche c'est impossible
bah oui on puisse lui montre la photo il
est mignon non il est pas mignon il
éclaté au sol mais tu veux faire quoi
non je
suis pas d'accord parce que c'est
subjectif la beauté c'est à dire qu'une
personne qui trouve quelqu'un de bois
c'est la vérité
c'est subjectif c'est super on dire la
vérité mais c'est mon point de vue moi
je dis la vérité j'ai une formation j'ai
mes chances laissait pas passer sa vie à
dire à son patron que son fils est moche
tu dis t'as pas demandé non mais
diplomatie la jeunesse des éléments moi
je pense surtout qu'on vit plus léger
avec une vérité qu'en ayant le coeur
lourd avec un mensonge pour écrire cette
phrase sur des chiffres de ce sens
je pense vraiment et en plus moi j'ai un
petit plaisir coupable c'est vrai j'ai
un petit instant je repère un petit peu
quand il ya un mensonge et fera un pur
plaisir à enfoncer les gens et à les
pousser dans leur montrer un délicieux
tout mais c'est ridicule à l'aîné
revenir sur le monde du travail il y a
quand même cette stat x statistiques sur
les français 65% d'entre nous
présenterait des cv qui est serait un
peu un peu bancal mais c'est normal en
même temps à la fois on se montre sous
son meilleur jour par exemple sur le
toit sur kindle ben voila si on pas
grave si on exemple des réseaux sociaux
on va pas se montrer avec en europe de
chant avec le cheveux sales et c'est
donc évidemment qu'on tranche
mentir sur un salaire est plutôt faire
faire état d'un diplôme ou d'une
compétence qu'on n'aurait pas vraiment
pour correspondre à un job mais tout
seul sourit mais oui mais je vous en
avais passé la [ __ ] vous le job il va
pas durer longtemps donc à la fois voilà
voilà l'ère de ces risques ou james hook
façon la vérité finit toujours par
sortir mais voilà nous dans tous les cas
ça sert absolument rien parce qu'à la
fin des courses toujours la vérité non
mais vous vous êtes où est l'intérêt
vous vous êtes à disneyland vous croyez
c'est le monde des bisounours vous vous
dites tout il faut pas mentir il faut
pas mentir tout le monde mais sinon non
je me dis que je ne mens pas jean-michel
oui c'est très bon trimestre avec de la
vie privée ou professionnelle à petite
ou à grande échelle tout le monde ment